♪ (music) ♪
(Narrator) It's great having
image support in Flutter,
loading images as assets
or over a network.
But what if you want
to tweak those images in some way,
adding rotation, skew, or even blur?
Flutter gives you
a simple way to do just that,
using a combination of the ImageFilter class
and the BackdropFilter widget.
The BackdropFilter widget takes
an ImageFilter and a child as parameters
and applies the filter
to widgets beneath the child.
First, decide what type
of filter you'd like--
blur or matrix,
which is used for transforms.
Next, give the widget a child,
but note that the child
won't be affected by the filter,
only those widgets beneath it.
Here's a handy tip.
To apply the filter to the background,
but not render anything visible
over the filter,
use an empty container as the child.
If you're not sure how to get started,
try using BackdropFilters with a stack.
Use Positioned.fill to ensure the filter
completely covers the widgets beneath it.
And you can easily apply the filter
to only a section,
selectively blurring out whatever you like.
For more info on BackdropFilter
and ImageFilter,
head on over to Flutter.io.
♪ (music) ♪